[Music]
with December already here many people
are dreaming about where to travel in
the new year at a recent survey found
that 58 percent of American Travelers
have a Leisure trip planned in the new
year and 51 percent have a trip planned
to visit friends and family so if you're
looking for inspiration Cody Nash
traveler is out with their new list the
23 best places to go in 2023 It's
featured in their December issue only on
CBS morning's Cody Nash Travelers Jesse
ashlock joins us to reveal their travel
destinations for the new year uh Jesse
thank you for being here so there's kind
of the aspirational and the attainable
and the aspirational there's some big
overseas trips here you've got Western
Japan British Columbia and Queensland
Australia why are they on the list well
Western Japan and Queensland Australia
are both places you couldn't visit the
last time we did this list so a big
thing is borders reopening on this list
which is super exciting and we've also
got Auckland New Zealand we've also got
Taiwan but I'd say Japan is the place
that our readers are most excited about
but Japan's usually an urban experience
and everybody discovered nature again
during the pandemic so we've showcased
Japan's nature with the Seto Inland Sea
where there are all these new Onsen real
cons where you can relax in a bath and
look at the snow-covered Mountains and
the Rice Terraces I've always wanted to
go there you've also got old classics
with a new look what do you mean well I
uh number one on that list would be
Egypt where finally at last the grand
Egyptian museum is opening next year
right in the shadow of the Giza Pyramids
and perhaps fittingly it's the 100th
anniversary of the discovery of tudon
Commons tomb so everything from two.com
is Tomb is in that museum as is 16
artifacts that the Met returned to Egypt
this year and a whole bunch of other
stuff it's going to be the largest
archaeological Museum in the world
anything in this country oh yeah so I
should had that we did a list a second
list that's all this country so for
readers who are budget conscious or
don't want to travel too far from home
you have tons and tons of options one of
my favorites because I was just there is
the Hudson Valley just Upstate New York
um and super beautiful bucolic locations
the where the Hudson River School
painted and so perhaps it's appropriate
now that it's becoming a prime Wellness
destination
um oh Bears Resorts has a new place
where I stayed it's beautiful called
Wildflower Farms the famous Mohawk
Mountain House has just read on their
spot and I'm sure you're familiar with
ranch Malibu yeah yeah so say hello to
the ranch Hudson Valley it's coming next
year really okay what about Memphis
Tennessee yeah Central California
northern and southern but this is new
Central California so I'm a California
boy and I'm not really that familiar
with this part of California and so it's
a place I want to go
um it's uh you know passive roebles has
been on kind of the wine lovers the
honophiles radar but it's becoming a
more well-rounded travel destination and
this santina's Valley has these Cowboy
towns I'm going to pleco Bears again
because they have a property called the
init mate Tavern and it's this cool
historic site that used to be a
stagecoach stop in the 1800s at a
Prohibition you're a hangout and now you
can stay there and Macon Georgia I I
haven't heard anyone say you know what
honey we need to go to Macon Georgia and
I'm not knocking Macon Georgia our
America list is full of places like that
that I'm learning from and I'm very
excited about so making Georgia
birthplace a little Richard birthplace
of Otis Redding
um and now the uh the home of the Merc
of Mercer music at Capricorn which is a
Music Center and museum dedicated to the
heritage of this place the musical
Heritage of this place
um just outside of town uh Okmulgee
Mounds historic site is a place where
these Earthworks that are thousands of
years old likely to be our next national
park wow good variety thank you so much
for joining us nice to be with you did
you bring extra magazines we'll be right
back oh yeah I got one for you guys okay
I really want one
[Music]